Colossus is a known character in the
Marvel Universe and what makes him
tricky to handle in the CG world is that
he is shiny oh because he's made
completely out of a metallic surface we
also have to do these reflection passes
in the environment whenever we finished
shooting our Colossus motion capture
actor we end up going in and we shoot
clean plates which just allow us to have
all the information that we need for
when Colossus moves around and then we
also shoot reflective gray balls and
reflective silver balls that allows the
visual effects artist to understand
where all the lighting sources are
coming from and then on top of that we
shoot HDR eyes with a still camera and
so we'll go in and they'll set up still
camera and they'll shoot all these
panoramic passes at multiple exposures
and those are to have reflection
information so that when the visual
effects artist put the sort of chrome
body on to Colossus they use that HDRI
information along with their reflection
passes to get sort of all of that
mapping of the environment around him
because he's essentially a giant mirror
that moves around and that allows
Jonathan and our sort of VFX team to
make this seamless transition into this
metallic person that moves like a human
and acts like a human but has this very
otherworldly form